i've got
people in me so saying the late abby
lincoln
i take that lyric as mantra
i've got people in me
joe mama jones is the person in me i
turn to
as a guide she's my alter ego
i've been embodying her in performance
since 1995
and she comes around when she has
some insight to offer folks at this time
of radical change i'm
glad to be the vessel for her message
to you
what if i told you it's going to be all
right
but what if i told you not yet what if i
told you there are trials ahead beyond
your deepest
fears what if i told you you will
fall down down down but
what if i told you you will surprise
yourself
what if i told you you will be brave
enough what if i told you
we won't all make it through
but what if i told you that is
as it must be what if i told you
i've seen the future
do you like my hands they're expressive
yes
now look at your hands they'll go on
there's so much
history recorded through their touches
and marks of the future
sketched on their palms sometimes hands
grip tight
sometimes hands let go
what if i told you it's
all going to come undone
ladies and gentlemen and otherwise
described
i am joe mama jones
some call me a soul sonic superstar and
i agree
no even in my past that was from the
future
let me take you back to girlhood picture
this
it was planting day which was a holiday
i'd invented
for the black youth community group i
found it i dashed home
to put on my gardening ensemble when i
caught
my uncle freeman red-handed he was
standing over my piggy bank
with his hammer raised high it was
fixing to steal my coins
you see my uncle freeman was a handyman
or he could fix anything a broken chair
a shattered pot
even bring grandmother's plants back to
life
he had that magic touch with broken
things
and broken people he would take me with
him on his jobs and
say come on joe let's go do something to
make this world a better place
you know his hands were wide and
calloused
they always reminded me of displaced
tree roots
as we worked he would he would talk with
folks
about the change he was sure was just
around the corner
i saw him mend flagging hopes
and leave folks with the heads held high
his hands
stirred the sunshine and now
he was about to break my piggy bank i
said step back man and show me your
hands
you know you know the irony was he used
to give me
all the old coins he'd find on the floor
boats while working
and i put them in the piggy bank along
with the money i earned through my
childhood side hustles but by the spring
of 1970
uncle freeman had lost his touch along
with
most of his jobs he
saw a heavy future of
civil wrongs and black power outages in
his palms
the last straw had come the previous
winter when
when they had gunned down fred hampton
overwhelmed with fear
and enrage and grief
uncle freeman tried to game his future
he gripped too
tight and he started playing the numbers
well one of these numbers gonna hit
little girl you got a quarter for your
uncle free
now some of y'all have that relative
but i knew right then and there i had to
do something
i jumped up and i grabbed that hammer
and i brought it crashing down on that
pig
oh and uncle freeman started to weep as
i gathered up all the coins
we're not buying no lottery ticket uncle
freeman come on
we spent every last cent
at the seed store you know the kids in
my gardening group
they didn't bat an eye when i had uncle
freeman get down and
and put his hands in the earth again and
start breaking up that soil for our
seeds
and my little friend taisha even came
over and started slapping him on the
back saying cry it out uncle freeman
cry it out i can't
fix this he sobbed
it's an ancient future truism that
he wasn't the first to feel that way and
he wouldn't be the last
right now it feels as though everything
is breaking beyond repair
it is but that breaking apart
can be a breaking open
no matter how violent and uncertain and
fearsome
it seems the thing is
we can't do it alone
uncle freeman cried so much that day as
we
planted our seeds he was our very own
irrigation
system
i don't know who i am anymore little
girl he said to me
at sundown good uncle freeman
good you're new again
and that's just how we need you
you